PRESENTER: Ladies
and gentlemen, Google
is happy to welcome Image Comics
creators of the title "Black
Jack Ketchum," Brian
Schirmer and Jeremy Saliba.
We're going to hear from
them about "Black Jack
Ketchum," the title,
and their work on it.
Gentlemen.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Thank you.
JEREMY SALIBA: Thanks, Chris.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: As
he said, I'm Brian.
He's Jeremy.
We started out doing
comics five, six years ago.
And what we're going to
be talking about today
is how we broke
into the big time
and now have a book
with Image Comics,
the premiere creator-owned
publisher in the US.
And probably the
best place to begin
is explaining what a
creator-owned comic
is versus any other kind.
Most people are obviously
familiar with your Batmans,
your Captain Americas, your
Avengers, your Justice League.
These are specifically owned
by companies-- DC Comics,
Marvel Comics.
And when someone is fortunate
to do work for either of them,
it is considered work for hire.
Conversely, when
you do something
that is creator-owned,
well, it's
exactly what it says on the tin.
That means that we as the
creators own everything.
We own the characters.
We own the stories.
We own the IP, most importantly.
And that's a cornerstone
of Image Comics.
JEREMY SALIBA: It's one
of those crown jewels
to be able to have your
own book, your own IP
with a book like this.
DC and Marvel are referred
to as the big two,
because they're the big dual
monoliths of the comic industry
and the ones that are
the most successful
in terms of reach
and publication
and amount of sales
and everything.
But Image is fast
approaching all that.
And there's a few
other-- there's actually
quite a few creator-owned comic
book publishers out there,
which is great.
And if you are the kind of
person who really values
getting into the
comic book industry,
and you do eventually want
to get to the big two,
it's also a great
place to start,
is the creator-owned area.
Because the big two
oftentimes want proof
that you can make a
book, and making a book
is the best way to prove
that you can make a book.
So usually, that's the
route that gets taken.
Not everyone is lucky enough to
get started at Image in terms
of a creator-owned publisher
that they get to work with.
But we somehow managed
to get that to happen.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Somehow.
And we'll talk
about that in part.
So we're really
going to be charting
the course of how-- kind of
like how a bill becomes a law,
this is how a comic goes from
a basic idea up into actually
being published.
In our case, I write.
I do a really bad ass stick
figure Batman that pretty
much only my students
ever get to see.
Jeremy wears many hats.
He edited the book.
He did the covers.
He was co-creator on it
along with Claudia Balboni,
who is the interior artist.
JEREMY SALIBA: She did
a tremendous amount
of work and a tremendous job.
She lives in Italy,
so she wasn't
able to make it here today.
Do we know where
in Italy she lives?
BRIAN SCHIRMER: In Roma.
JEREMY SALIBA: In Rome
itself, which is awesome.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: I'm sorry if
I'm-- I've got to apologize.
Claudia, I'm sorry if I
butcher your name or butcher
your accent.
I'm going to have the equivalent
of an Italian fatwa on me,
which is a vendetta, actually.
Moving on.
So every story, whether it's
a comic, a film, a book,
comes from a basic idea.
In this instance, Black Jack
Ketchum came from two places.
The first one was family ties.
My great-great-grandmother
on my mother's side
was a cousin of a gentleman
by the name of Tom Ketchum.
This is probably one of the
more famous pictures of him.
Unfortunately, he came to
a rather dire end in 1901,
I want to say.
And if I'm getting that
wrong, that's embarrassing.
That's a more favorable
picture of him to a degree.
I think this was actually taken
shortly before he was hung.
So he was a wanton,
rapscallion outlaw
in the late 19th century.
And as I say, he was cousin
to my great-great-grandmother.
And this was the story that
was passed down from when
I was four or five years old.
I would hear my aunts
and uncles and my mom
and my grandparents
talking about Blackjack
Ketchum, Blackjack Ketchum.
I didn't really know
anything about the guy
until I got older and
started to research
and found out that he was
a little touched, I think,
is probably the best way, a
favorable way of saying it.
He had issues.
And there are various
stories out there
talking about how he
was too crazy to ride
with the Wild Bunch and too
crazy to hang out with Butch
Cassidy and the Sundance Kid.
And eventually, he robbed the
wrong train at the wrong time
and got himself shot,
got himself captured,
and eventually got himself hung
in a very mismanaged execution,
shall we say.
So I never really
had any, necessarily,
plans to do anything
with the story
until only a few years ago.
I had a dream.
I had an actual dream that
involved a Western setting
where the typical
tropes had basically
been turned on their heads.
It was a very surrealistic
fever dream involving
guys in duster coats that had
no faces, kind of like Nazgul
in the Old West, and saloons
where you would enter one
saloon and you could
exit any other saloon
anywhere in the world.
And just a myriad
of bizarre things.
And I woke up.
I woke up, and
believe it or not,
I found just this
morning without-- this
is the actual notebook
where I scrawled down
the dream that I had.
And at the very top
on the second page,
it says this all came at the end
of a post-coffee sleep of about
five hours on the morning
of February 20th, 2012.
So combining those,
about a year or so later,
started to put together
the idea for a comic that
would be called
"Black Jack Ketchum,"
and taking this
historical figure
and throwing him into
this surrealist landscape.
And then we were
off and running.
JEREMY SALIBA: One of
the interesting things
about when you have a story
is that there's always
a few avenues in which you can
tell it-- movies, television,
comics, books, web blog,
whichever avenue you choose.
And in terms of mass
production and strong visuals
accompanying it,
comics seems to be
one of the last American
storytelling art forms
where it's really still pure.
One person, if talented enough
to write and draw and do
all those things together, can
sit down and make their story.
And they can assemble it in
the way that they want to,
and then bring it to a
publisher, or perhaps a few,
before they're told yes and
have it released that way.
You can also self-publish.
There's a lot of
ways you can do it.
But it's one of those,
again, art forms that
seems to be one of
the last ones where
if-- obviously, on a movie,
it's a much larger production,
and many more
people are involved,
and there's a lot more money
involved in making a movie.
So the money people tend to want
to have their say in how things
go so they make sure they get
a return on their investment.
But with comics,
it's a lot more free.
It's a lot more open
and experimental.
And it's a really
exciting place.
And there's a
legitimacy in comics
that wasn't there when I was
growing up reading comics.
People look to them
for great storytelling
now-- be it outside of
fantastical elements
and outside of
superhero pow, bang,
punch, which is really exciting.
And so Brian has written for
several mediums over the years,
but had started getting into
comics at this point, which
is probably, I think,
one of the reasons
why one of your first ideas was
to make it into a comic book.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Yeah.
And because we had-- we had
been doing some self-publishing
for a while.
We did some stuff
via Kickstarter
and basically
opened a few doors.
And one of those
doors was opened
to Eric Stephenson, who's the
publisher of Image Comics.
And he basically said,
well, what do you guys got?
And one of the
things-- we sent him
a couple pitches,
and one of them
was indeed for
"Black Jack Ketchum."
And this is the cover
that Jeremy mocked up
for when we were
submitting the proposal.
When pitching to-- it
varies by publisher
what they want to see when
you're pitching a new project.
In this instance, I think
he wanted to see a cover
and I think about five pages.
And it was basically a
one-page proposal of here's
what the story is
going to be about.
It's about a C-grade outlaw
who's mistaken for an A-lister
and has to try and clear his
name in a surrealist version
of the Old West.
And we went into a little more
detail and talked about some
of the characters.
And based on all of this--
it was all done via e-mail.
Except I met him in person,
and the actual pitching process
was completely handled by email.
And I'd say over the course of
maybe five, six weeks-- which
isn't a long time in comics--
finally got the green light
to go ahead and make the book.
As fate would have it,
though, we got the green light
September, 2014.
And about six weeks
later, our artist
had to leave the project.
He was a young man
named Valerio Fabbretti.
We had worked with
him previously
on some self-published stuff.
However, in that time, his
star had shone very brightly.
And after about six weeks, he
contacted me and said, look,
I've got these other
deals going on.
I'm not going to be
free for 18 months.
And the prospect of having to
put this on the back burner
for over a year did
not sit very well.
And we all agreed
that it would be
best if we went ahead and found
someone new to take the reins.
JEREMY SALIBA: We did, and
it was-- first it was panic.
What do you mean, you
can't do the book?
Oh no.
How long do we have to wait?
And then, yes, OK, well,
let's try and figure out
who we can get.
And one of the nice things about
having a book that's already
been approved to be made
at Image Comic Books
is that people are a lot more
interested than if you're just
some person who has a story
who says, oh, you can--
it's great experience,
great exposure for you
to work on the book.
It was a little bit
more to offer with that.
So we had a unique
situation in that
we wanted to find
another artist,
but we didn't have any
one lined up per se.
And we sent out some feelers.
And a smattering of artists
were introduced to us via email,
and said all these people
heard about your project,
thought it sounds awesome,
they want to work on it.
So we were trying to think
what would be the best
way to sift through all this.
Some of them had portfolios.
Some of them didn't.
We ended up having-- everyone
agreed that they would go ahead
and do some test work, some
tests rough pages for the book
so we could take a
look at all of them
and see which one
was the best fit.
It was amazing.
Everyone was awesome.
We had some tremendous
artwork delivered our way.
They were very generous
with their time.
We did our best to make sure
everyone knew exactly what was
going on up front, that
we were trying to pitch,
and we're not sure which
artist we want to go with.
Would you be interested in
trying some and donating
your time?
And they said yes, sure.
And great work all around.
Unique choices, really
cool art styles.
But ultimately,
Claudia's was the one
that just seemed like it was
the best fit for the book
and the style and
the storytelling
that we wanted to do.
We got the pages and
immediately-- her pages
and went, oh yeah.
That's the one that
seems to really resonate
the most with the story
and the character.
And it was, again,
a great position
to be in, because there was no
bad choices put in front of us.
But hers was a good one.
And we ended up putting
to the publisher a few
together, saying here's some
great artwork, the best stuff
that we think we got.
We're leaning towards Claudia,
because we like her work a lot.
And that was when we heard
back, and Eric Stephenson
said yes, she seems
like a great fit.
Let's go ahead and
move forward with her.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And then
we were off and running.
And that was January of 2015.
And so it was like, OK.
We've got the green light.
You've got the artist.
You've got the creative team.
Go make your book.
That's basically
how Image operates.
They say, oh, OK, sure.
Go do it.
Don't pester us until it's done.
And so we spent the better part
of last year putting this book
together.
So then begs the
question, well, OK.
You got the green light.
What do you do?
How do you make the comic?
What are the steps?
And, well, we're
here to tell you.
This insane-- yeah,
that's a comic, folks.
That's basically
what it looks like.
The very first
thing before-- you
have a cursory idea, the
first thing that you typically
want to do is outline.
Outlining-- it terrifies
a lot of people.
A lot of people just
hate the prospect,
because they figure, oh, it's
taking all the creativity out
of it.
It took me a long time to
get over that bridge myself.
I am very much of the
mind that outlining
is one of the freest parts
of creating anything,
because you're not
locked into anything.
Nothing is set in stone.
There's a Brian Eno
quote that is something
along the lines of, you're
not building a wall,
you're making a brick,
which I translate
to it's not a wall between
you and your creativity.
It's the foundation of what you
are going to do with the story.
JEREMY SALIBA:
Speaking of walls,
it's interesting, because
this is somewhat conservative.
I've seen you do
outlines before.
As he mentioned,
he and I had done
some-- we just did some
self-publishing for a while
just to make books, because
we just wanted to make books.
And one of the times that
you were really working out
one of your biggest stories,
it was a whole entire wall
you had mapped out with
all the beats of stories
and all the different options.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: To be fair,
what we're looking at here,
I believe on the one side
is my chicken scratch
and stuff scribbled out
for part of one issue.
And then what you see in
the multi-colored note
cards on my bed was, I
think, the final issue
and being able to move all of
that around as needed and hit
the right beats.
But if we had something
that was the entire series,
need a much bigger monitor.
So you start with an outline.
You get it to where
you want it to be.
And then the next thing is my
bailiwick, which is scripting.
You Googlers might recognize
this little program here.
Yeah.
I've long since moved on
from anything like Word.
I'm not one of the
guys-- there are
writers and comics out
there who use Final Draft
and various other softwares.
Google Docs, for me, is ideal.
It's a one-stop shop.
I can share it with all of the
artists and the creative team
and anybody else that needs it.
I can put links in there.
You might see-- it's just great.
For reference for the
artists, it can't be beat.
And I sound like I'm kissing
Google ass right now,
and that's not my intent.
But it's just been
a fantastic tool.
Unlike screenplays,
as some of you
might know-- so screenplays have
a very, very strict and rigid
format to the degree that
there are plenty of stories
out there in Hollywood where
if a producer or a reader
gets a script and it's
not properly formatted,
they don't even bother.
They just delete it.
They throw it in
the trash, whatever.
Comics are not that at all.
There is no formalized
comic script.
And right now, my
students are screaming,
because I tell them a
lie, because I don't want
to see 20 different formats.
But mine is a
hodgepodge of what I've
seen others do in the industry.
And so it's a little
bit like a screenplay.
It's a little bit
like a stage play.
Basically, what you're
doing in a script is
you're telling the
artist what you
think, what you as the writer
think will appear on a page,
what you think will appear in
each panel-- and for my money,
using as few words as
possible so you're not
miring them down in detail.
JEREMY SALIBA: Now, in
terms of formats of scripts,
there's the Marvel method
for script writing,
for instance, which is where you
just give suggestions of what's
happening on the page.
BRIAN SCHIRMER:
What he's referring
to as the Marvel method was
something that, ostensibly,
Stan Lee pioneered
back in the '60s when
he, if you believe
the apocrypha,
was writing basically everything
that Marvel was putting out
at that point.
And he didn't have enough time.
There weren't enough
hours in the day
to do a detailed script.
So he would, on occasion,
do an entire script
for, say, Fantastic
Four or the Avengers,
and it would be one page.
It would be one page
of just a synopsis.
And he would give it to the
artist and say go make this.
And the artist, who might
be Steve Ditko, Jack Kirby,
would go away, sometimes
for as brief as a weekend,
and come back with 20 pages
of art and say, here, Stan,
take all the credit.
JEREMY SALIBA: And
then from that point,
then you start crafting
dialogue and doing
it to fit the images
that were drawn as well.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Right.
So Stan or whomever
would be putting
in the dialogue and
the captions and sound
effects and everything
after the fact,
after all the art
had been completed.
Whereas the more common
scripting method these days
is probably the full
script method, which
is pretty much what I do, where
you are, as the writer, saying,
again, this is what
happens on each page.
This is what happens in
each panel on each page.
This is the dialogue.
These are the captions,
so on and so forth.
A big thing that I
advocate and that I do
is every script that
I send to an artist,
I begin first by praising them.
Because who doesn't love praise?
But also, by saying, look,
you are the illustrator.
You're the artist.
I can write.
I can do story.
I can do dialogue.
I can do character work.
But you are the visual artist.
If you see something
in here and you
think you can do
it better-- if I
say this needs to be
done in five panels,
and you think you can do it in
two, or in one big panel, one
splash page, go for it.
I trust you.
And we're in this together.
JEREMY SALIBA: It's that
collaborative aspect
that starts to make
it really exciting.
That's where the magic happens.
Because obviously,
with scripting,
it runs the full gamut of here,
Spider-Man fights Dr. Octopus,
go, all the way to page 1,
panel 1, Spider-Man wakes up,
Peter Parker turns off
his alarm clock, whatever.
And Brian, as a writer, working
with him and his writing
over the years, he's
a generous writer.
As he says, he says
he has links in here.
He'll provide reference.
He'll provide an
outline of the page.
But it's totally
malleable in terms
of what can happen on
there, because we're
after the best product.
And theoretically,
the assumption
is that the artist
will also have
a really good knowledge of what
will look good on the page.
And that's the best
of both worlds.
Because you're getting a
version of it, and you read it.
And I know that having
drawn his words before,
reading the words, you start
to form a picture in your head
as you read it, and
sometimes it disagrees
with what he's written.
So you make a note, and
then you go back and forth
about it a little bit.
But that collaborative aspect
tends to really not only just
get the best possible result
out of what you're making,
but also, it tends to-- you have
that trial by fire a little bit
where you start to question
things a little bit
and make sure that
you're arriving
at the best possible
conclusion for all of it.
And it's also the one
that's the best fit, too.
Sometimes, the artist--
there's been some interiors
that I've drawn for Brian
before where he said, OK.
Brian is a guy who likes--
he's always been a fan,
he's read comics of almost
schematic-like drawings.
If Batman is going
to the Bat Cave,
and it's a hugely detailed,
full-page drawing of the Bat
Cave, and every little bat
computer and all the trophies
he has-- he's written
pages like that for me,
and I would not like
to draw that at all.
That sounds very
difficult and not fun.
So I said, how about
instead we have
him walking past some
things and some panels,
and you see one thing
here and one thing there?
And we get the same idea
across, because my weaknesses
were going to be on display
too much for a page like that.
And he'll go OK, yes.
That works just fine.
We can do that.
So that collaboration
hopefully finds the best fit
as well, which should result
in the best-looking book.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And the
initial proof of this
is, again, send the
script to the artist--
in this case, Claudia.
And so she takes it.
She goes away.
She reads it.
She thinks about it.
She puts it under her
pillow-- virtually,
of course, because it's
all in Google Docs.
And then she takes
her time and does what
are basically called roughs.
So what we've got
here are the roughs
or thumbnails--
another colloquialism--
for every page out of the first
issue of "Black Jack Ketchum."
You want to talk about
that a little bit?
JEREMY SALIBA: Well, sure.
The rough process is just
like the outlining process
for writing.
It's one of the more exciting
ones, because anything goes.
The most common question
I get from people
who are starting off with
the roughs will be, well,
how rough can they be?
And as long as
they're readable, it
can be stick figures if it's
readable and understandable
what's going on.
Usually, it's a little
bit more than that.
But the main part here
is that you're really
blocking in stuff.
You don't want to spend
a lot of time on this.
This is something
where you're just
getting that initial
idea out and hoping
to communicate it really
well and leave enough room.
This is disposable
artwork, usually,
at this stage of the project,
because something might not
be working.
Oftentimes, changes need to be
made, quick little adjustments.
Then there are some people
who can just do these roughs,
and it's perfect
right from the start.
Most people, it's
obviously a combination.
Some things are good and some
things are not working as well.
But you can see,
too, there's a lot
of-- in terms of a comic page--
and Claudia was obviously
here dealing with the black
and white aspect of it
and the heavy black
inked areas as well as
the more open white areas.
And these black areas are
what we call spot blacks.
And they're a design
element as well.
You try to not only do good,
solid work that represents
people, places,
things like that,
but also try to lead
the eye with those spot
blacks around the page, or set
the mood or anything like that.
There's also a flow that
goes into a comic book page
that you've got to
try and keep in mind.
Basically, we all read from top
to bottom and right to left.
So we want to--
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Left to right.
JEREMY SALIBA: Left to right.
Top to bottom, left to right.
And a comic book page
should flow similarly.
And you want the
page, when it ends,
to go off out the bottom on
the right side of the page
off to the next one.
And so the idea is that
you kind want a backwards S
curve to go through the page
as much as you can with all
those different elements.
And hopefully, again,
starting up here,
coming down through it, and
then ultimately swooshing out
there, which leads you
right up, of course,
to the next page or to
turn the page depending
on the spacing there.
And this is also--
as much as you
don't want to spend too
much time on the drawing
aspect of it, it's
because there's
a lot of planning going on
at this stage-- not just
in the layout of the panels
and the layout of the design
of those spot blacks and
everything like that,
but also the continuity
of what's going on.
A very specific
example of that would
be the 180 rule or
crossing the line, which
is when you're having two
characters deliver dialogue
to each other-- and
this applies to movies
or whatever-- when
they're facing each other,
there's an imaginary
line between them.
And you want that camera
that goes between them when
one talks and the other talks to
stay on one side of that line.
Otherwise, it
starts to disorient
the viewer a little bit.
If you want a scene to be
confusing-- which sometimes,
you do-- you do move
the camera around more.
But if you want it to just
be something easy to follow,
you keep on that same
side of that line.
So essentially, as it works
out, the person talking
may be in the foreground on
the left side of the panel,
and the person in
the background is
on the right side of the panel.
And then you cut
to their back side.
Well, then they're still on
the same side of the panel.
It's very easy to
follow and read.
And you want to make sure
that's organized as well
and flows as easily and
smoothly as possible.
Because if you're
making the reader
do hard work to
decipher and understand
what they're trying
to see, they're
going to put the book down.
We don't want that.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And
as he was saying,
these are very, very akin to the
outline that the writer does.
So there are a lot of
changes that can be made.
Again, sometimes you
will get in roughs
like what Claudia gave us,
and we'll look at them,
and it's like, great.
Everything is perfect.
I can't wait to see, blow
this up into an actual page.
But every once in a
while, it will be,
oh, no this is in
the wrong place.
Or you didn't
really-- what I wrote
did not communicate clearly
what would happen in this panel
or on this page,
and there will be
adjustments that would be made.
And usually, that
was not a problem.
And then so once we
receive all of these
and Jeremy looks at
them as the editor,
and I look at them
as the co-creator,
and we both give the thumbs up,
then Claudia is off and running
and starts moving forward.
So this is actually a
closeup of one of the roughs
that we were just
looking at featuring
the dusters who, again, came
from my dream, god help me.
And this just shows
you the process
of going from a rough of a
page actually to the final.
So this was the rough
thumbnail that she
did, which we scaled up a little
bit for these purposes, which
then became this.
And Claudia works digitally,
so these were her digital inks.
These are her final inks, right?
And then the next step was
bringing in some color,
which we have there.
And you get a little more of
the depth and otherworldly
nature of these characters.
And then finally, the
unsung hero of comicdom--
you get some letters.
You get some words in
there, a little dialogue
balloon for this poor guy.
Speaking about dialogue,
I think I might be jumping
a little bit, but that's OK.
So once the final art
comes in, like I say,
the unsung hero, the
letterer, comes in
and has to do all
kinds of crazy things.
JEREMY SALIBA:
Actually, if you go back
to that rough real
quick-- even further
back to the page of roughs.
One of the things
that-- he's right,
it's an unsung hero of the
comics world, the workhorse.
Not only do you have to
make room for everything
to happen on the page,
but you have to leave room
for dialogue, too.
That's one of my greatest sins.
Whenever I do a panel or a page,
Brian goes, that looks great,
but where am I going
to put my words?
And words, who needs those?
It's the art.
That's what's important.
So it's a phase of the process
that not everyone talks about,
not everyone focuses on.
But it ends up
being-- I don't know,
a large amount of
work, one could say,
a decent amount of work in
terms of laying out the dialogue
balloons and choosing a font.
These days, most lettering
is done digitally,
and one of those arts that's
getting a little bit more
homogenized, I guess,
to a certain degree.
But there is a lot of
rules regarding lettering.
And it's something that
can be easily overlooked,
and it's something really
important keep in mind.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Yeah.
In my experience, it
is not uncommon to have
at least a couple
pages per issue
come in where I will need
to write back to the artist
and say, this is gorgeous.
This is gorgeous.
Can you cheat it down
like 25%, because I've
got to put the little
dialogue balloon right there.
But oddly enough, one of
the happiest experiences
I have in making comics is when
a page of art will come in.
It could be a page.
It could just be a panel.
And I look at it, and I
realize that the artist
has captured everything
that needed to be said.
So the words that I had
written-- dialogue, caption,
whatever-- I can
just throw them out.
On the one hand, that's great.
It's just like,
ah, that's awesome.
You took that away.
That's fantastic.
On the other hand,
it's like, awesome.
A little less lettering
that I have to do.
Because yes, I did the
lettering for the book as well.
I enjoy it.
It's a sickness.
And so basically, what
we're showing here
is you can actually--
peeking through those two
images is a copy of the script.
And that's-- we're just
basically copying the text
right out of there, dropping
it into Adobe Illustrator,
and making dialogue balloons,
and putting in the words,
and making it right.
JEREMY SALIBA: There's
an art to that, too.
Some words need to be bold.
Some words need to be a
little bit more pushed.
Do you change the
color of the dialog box
to add clarity of who's talking?
You never want to leave
too much negative space
around the dialog
in a dialog box
or a word balloon or a
caption or anything like that.
There's a lot of things
to balance with that, too.
It's shocking how much needs
to be done with that stage.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And
then that brings us
to a little more breakdown
of the various stages
of single pages from the roughs
at the very top, to the inks,
down to the colored and lettered
portions of various pages.
I think this is out
of Issue 3 maybe.
JEREMY SALIBA: As someone
who co-created and edited
the book, some of these
pages, I remember them
in the late nights.
Because there can be there
can be a lot of organization
to do and clarity.
And this is one of the scenes.
Is this from Issue 3
or is this Issue 4?
BRIAN SCHIRMER: 3.
JEREMY SALIBA: In Issue 3, this
is a shootout that takes place.
And there's a lot of
different characters.
And you try not to have
anything be too superfluous.
You want it to all have
a reason and be there.
And for someone who
maybe goes back and wants
to re-read the book or look
for something they missed,
I like to give them
something that's there.
So organizing all these
multiple staged elements,
and where people
move, and does it
read clearly-- that was
where I was up late a lot,
looking at these
things and squinting
my eyes as they watered.
And staring at a screen,
and making sure that,
hopefully, it all
moved through clearly.
But it can be pretty fun.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And this
is actually something
I haven't thought about.
A random page, how
much time do you think
is spent cumulatively?
How much time does
she take to do
the roughs, and then how much
time to do the inks, and then
the colors?
And the letters are minuscule.
JEREMY SALIBA: With
her in particular,
it would be hard
to say for sure.
Typically, most artists,
it takes them a month
to do a 22-page book.
And some artists are working
16-hour days six days a week,
and some artists are working
eight-hour days five days
a week.
So it depends, because some
people draw a little more
quickly.
Some people do a
little more graphically
and have a more simplified,
edited-down style,
where some people go a
lot more illustrative
and have a lot more
detail into it.
But the rule of thumb in
comics is you've got a month.
And if you're not
very fast, then that
means you don't have much of
a weekend or evenings, either.
And if you are a little quicker
or find a way through it all,
you can get a little more time.
Now, these days
in comics, that's
a pace that doesn't always
get held for very long.
And artists-- what
they'll run on a book,
if it's an ongoing
series-- something
like, again, from the big two
or an ongoing image title,
an artist typically
will go-- you
see them run for about
six months-- six months,
maybe a year where
they're keeping that pace.
And then they switch off.
They'll take some time off.
Another artist
comes in, steps in.
Another very popular
book from Image Comics,
Saga, they do
annual breaks where
they put out a trade
collected version of it,
because the artist needs--
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Which
is kind of becoming
the norm for the
publisher at this point.
So they'll basically do four,
five, six issues of an arc.
They'll take a break.
They'll put out the
collected edition,
and then they'll resume,
allowing the artist
time to get ahead, basically, so
that they don't miss deadlines.
So that everything
comes out as scheduled.
Do you want to talk about
cover process a little bit?
JEREMY SALIBA: Sure.
So the covers-- I have
done covers more often
than I've done tiers in comics.
So I offered-- said if you guys
need covers, I can do that,
but I'm happy to edit.
And Claudia was very
gracious and generous
and said, oh, I would
think that would be great.
So we had a lot of
ideas for covers.
And this is just a small
sampling of some of the ideas
we explored.
I did more thumbnails
for these books
than I've done
for any other book
ever before, because
we really wanted
to-- the purpose of a
cover is to sell the book,
to grab someone's eye.
If it's sitting on
the shelves, you
want it to stand
out from the rest.
And we had some great
concepts initially.
We had one where we knew we
were going to have four issues,
so what if we did each
cover was a playing
card, like a face card,
like jack, king, queen, ace.
And how would we handle that?
But nothing was
really standing out.
And usually, thumbnails
are started off
with just liner value.
So I was referencing
some other ideas.
This was a play off of
the movie The Professional
up there at the top, and just
staging some different things
around it.
We weren't hitting it.
Nothing was happening.
And one of the big things
was it wasn't weird enough.
And the iconography of the
West needs to be there.
If I changed away from dusters
and horses and guns and rifles,
then it didn't feel
like the West anymore.
But at the same time, it
just felt a little bit
just too Westerny.
And then I said,
well, I think color
is going to be the next phase
that we need to think about,
then.
I needed to sit
down and do color,
because that's where
I can get weird.
We can keep the Western
iconography intact
so it's very clearly a Western.
But then if I do psychedelic,
more surrealistic colors,
then that's going to be
that right combination.
And this particular page--
I did these all in a day.
And normally, I
could do something
like this in half a day,
but it took me the full day
to do these, and a
lot of concentration.
I had to have all the music
off and the door to my office
closed, and really sit
and think about the ideas
that I wanted to put down.
And a lot of it-- it's color
theory, warm versus cool colors
and things like that.
And then from there, it goes to
a lot of feedback and getting
impressions from people.
So after months of--
really, literally
months of doing
different thumbnails
and sending them to Brian,
us going back and forth,
I sent him this and
he went, this is it.
I think he was
very, very excited.
There was lots of exclamation
points in the email
that he sent back in return.
And he said, I think we might
have covers for all the books
here if look
through them enough.
Some of my favorites just
didn't make the cut, though.
It just doesn't work.
I like these a lot.
But everyone is like,
oh, so the Japanese flag?
Does it take place in Japan?
As much as I wish
Japan didn't own
the idea of a white background
with a red circle on it,
they do.
You can't do it without
getting away from that.
So we had to just scrap
those ideas out of hand.
But this is the cover
for the first one.
This is the cover for the
second one and the third one.
And then the fourth one was a
little bit more of an original,
straight from Brian's
head, I think.
BRIAN SCHIRMER:
These were the four
that we initially went with,
with the original logo that we
had for the book.
JEREMY SALIBA: I
loved this logo.
We had this little
hang man game.
Because obviously, the real
Ketchum had been hanged.
And what Brian had mentioned
is that at Little Grizzly,
they had botched his
hanging, and he was
decapitated when he was hanged.
Yeah.
So it's a fun thing to play
with with the character.
So that was a logo.
That was a logo that
we brainstormed,
and I really liked it.
But we ended up
going with something
a bit more streamlined.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And these were
the final that we went with.
But as Jeremy said,
those first three
were right from
that one day of him
sitting down and
brainstorming that about eight
or 10 different covers.
I hadn't thought
about it in a while,
but reflecting
back on that, it's
like, wow, you nailed--
especially those two
in the middle, I
had seen nothing.
He did those on that
day, and we carried them
through to the final.
And that one on the
end, the fourth one,
which is actually going to
be the cover of the collector
edition, was-- I think
we basically sat down
and emailed back and
forth saying, OK.
So this is going to be Issue 4.
It's going to be
the trade cover.
I'll probably make a banner
out of it for conventions,
so it's got to have everything.
How are we going to fit it
all in there and make it cool?
JEREMY SALIBA: This is where
his generosity comes into play
in his collaborative aspect.
It made it easy,
because he showed me
the compositions that he liked,
and ways we could arrange it,
more of a triangular
composition.
Which I always think
of Frank Frazetta
when I think of
triangular compositions,
which is a cool way to go.
And the "Star Wars"
poster, the original one's
kind of a triangular
composition.
It has a lot of elements in it.
And Brian knew he wanted
that crazy cast that
shows up throughout the
book, all in there as well.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And
then-- basically, hey, we
did everything.
We put it in.
And this is-- God help me.
This is me in a comic
shop in New York
City, Fall of 2015-- that
was last October-- holding
previews.
So Diamond Distributors is the
one-stop shop comic distributor
for the United States.
And they have a catalog they
put out every month that
goes to every retailer.
And your average person
can buy it as well.
And this is the catalog
they use to market books
as they're coming out,
issues as they're coming out.
And this was my first
time seeing it in print
and documenting it.
JEREMY SALIBA: In the
wild, as they say.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And
so this is, again,
what retailers would be looking
at and deciding, hmm, am
I going to order this book.
And if so, how many
am I going to get?
So we did OK.
I'll say that much.
And then-- so there's
previews, which
was the magazine, catalog.
Then we have reviews
and interviews.
And that's all on the
promotional trail for it
to get-- first to get
retailers to order the book.
Because it's one thing
to be in a catalog,
but what I didn't
really show you
on there is the catalog for
previews is over an inch thick.
It's probably about
an inch and a half
thick on an average month.
So you're competing
with hundreds of pages
of thousands of other titles.
So we had to get out
there and wave the flag
in any way we could doing
interviews, doing interviews,
doing podcasts, sending people
advance previews of the book,
so on and so forth.
And then eventually putting
together things like this,
where we were taking quotes from
other folks in the industry,
other writers and artists, other
websites that had covered us.
And then use that for
further marketing,
sending that to both stores and
just putting it on social media
to raise awareness
amongst potential readers.
JEREMY SALIBA: It's
one of the things
about comics, too, is that
the retail side of it-- the
stores themselves are what
dictate what your sales are.
You think it's the neutral
person, the customers going
to the stores.
But it's really how
much can you get
the retailers to
get interested in it
and assure them that
they'll make money buying
a lot of copies of your book.
They have small shops.
They're not sitting back in the
back with fat cigars going, ah,
this is the life, a comic shop.
They have to be very
judicious about what
books they order, not having too
many not selling or whatever.
So with a new book
like this, they
tend to be cautious, so
we knew that was going
to be a big target for us.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And
then once everything
came to fruition--
this was seconds
after opening my box of comps,
which every creator gets
a certain amount of free
copies of their own book.
And this is when--
oddly enough, I
expected that when this arrived,
when I held it in my hand,
it's like oh, it feels real.
And I was a little disappointed.
I took it out, and it was like,
it still doesn't feel real.
This doesn't feel legit.
And I'm not too sure when that
moment actually kicked in.
It might have been,
actually, when
we finally-- when
the book was out,
and we started doing signings.
And some of these are
from the first day
it came out, and did a signing
in a store in the East Bay.
And then being able to
go out to other shops
and just seeing it
sitting on shelves.
And occasions like this
where it was actually a staff
pick with some little
handwritten promotion
from one of the
workers there, which
is always kind of cool
to see it in the wild.
I think that's us.
PRESENTER: Should we
cut to some questions?
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Yeah.
PRESENTER: So thank
you, Brian and Jeremy.
Does anybody have
questions for these guys?
Anne.
AUDIENCE: Do you have an
international audience?
The French are into
graphic novels.
BRIAN SCHIRMER:
Short answer, yes.
Longer answer, the
book is already
out in the United Kingdom.
Image Comics partners
with a company
down in LA who handles
international rights
and distribution.
So from what I've
been told, this
should start happening for
us sometime this summer,
where they will go in
and they will actually
do translations of everything,
which I'm very, very eager
to see.
And I mentioned to the woman
who is the rep for Image Comics
from this company that
our artist is in Rome.
And she said, oh,
that'll be great.
I was like, can we set
up a signing in Italy
and go there and have the
Italian version of "Black Jack
Ketchum?"
It would be fantastic.
JEREMY SALIBA: (WITH ITALIAN
ACCENT) "Black Jack-a Ketchum."
BRIAN SCHIRMER: He said it.
I didn't.
PRESENTER: Other questions?
AUDIENCE: About the financing--
you described the process
from getting a green light.
And how does the finance
process, and maybe even
distribution go, for
the slightly different,
nontraditional Marvel or DC?
BRIAN SCHIRMER: By and large,
there is no money up front,
which is also one
of the things--
when Jeremy said we were
vetting replacement artists,
we had to basically tell
people, hey, on the plus side,
if you get chosen, you're going
to have a book from Image.
The downside is you're
probably not going
to see any money from
that for several months.
So Image pays on the
back end, which basically
means the book gets released,
the book gets ordered
by stores, the
stores pay Diamond,
the distributor, and
then Diamond pays Image,
and then Image pays us.
So to put it in a
similar perspective,
the first issue of
"Black Jack Ketchum"
came out last December.
We didn't get paid
until February.
And that was over a
year since Claudia
was approved to be the
replacement artist and almost
a year and a half from the
moment we got greenlit.
So it can take a while.
JEREMY SALIBA: It will vary
a little bit from one book--
obviously with the
big two, it's a job.
It's a contract,
freelance kind of job,
so you get paid
a rate as you go.
But someone like big names--
we're not quite there yet.
But with some of the bigger
names in the industry,
they can give a
little money upfront
to get things going
on for the books.
But otherwise, the
benefit is that Image
handles all the production costs
and everything with regards
to printing and all
that kind of stuff.
And then they take
a flat rate for what
it costs to print it
out of your profits.
And again, from there,
deals work out individually.
Sometimes they have a
little bit of percentage.
I don't know if that's
all the time that they
have a percentage from things.
But ultimately, they handle all
that stuff on the front end,
and we just work
it out ourselves
on the back end,
the different rates.
AUDIENCE: I'd love to hear
more of the process of being
the lead artist but not
the lead illustrator,
and how you project
manage that and make sure
it executes your guy's
vision without creatively
stifling any of your partners.
JEREMY SALIBA: Yeah.
It's funny, because I definitely
had a vision in my head
for everything.
And then Claudia, she's
got a really unique style,
and it's very specific to
her, which was awesome.
We wanted that.
So what it comes down to is the
more academic side of things.
Does it read?
Does it work?
Are we crossing the line at
all, those kinds of elements.
So for the most part--
every now and then,
something would be a little
bit more pushed design-wise,
or a little bit more loose,
or a little bit tighter, even,
than maybe I had imagined.
And I'll have an
initial reaction to it,
and I'll talk to Brian and
say, hey, does this read?
Does it look good?
And he'll go yeah, it looks
great, or I'm not sure either.
And then I might even seek out a
few other friends at that point
and say, look.
Because I don't-- I know
that I have preferences,
and I don't always
trust myself with that.
Because there's a lot of room
for a lot of different styles.
So I'll seek out especially
people whose tastes
are different from mine and see
if it reads really well still.
But for the most part, I just
try to keep it as-- in terms
of perspective and anatomy
and things like that,
as long as it's-- it's hard
to define the cool factor,
but as long as it's cool.
And that's where, I think,
spending the last-- whatever,
30 years of my
life reading comics
and going through them all, you
start of get a sense for yeah,
this can play.
I'm the one-- out
of the three of us,
I was the one who was
most concerned about.
Are people going to
want to buy this book?
Brian's writing is
little more esoteric.
He's a little bit
more-- he likes
to push the boundaries of
realism and things like that.
And Claudia was totally on
board with that and yeah,
let's do it.
And I was like,
OK, but let's also
make sure it's
accessible to people.
And yeah, you with your
traditional whatever.
So I would be the one who
leaned that way, I think,
the most out of the three of us.
So I was the strict
school mistress
smacking the back with a
ruler or something, and going,
does this work?
Luckily, though, Brian knows
exactly what he wants out
of these things, too.
So there would be things
where I'd say, I don't know.
This is a little bit weird.
And he's like, that's
how it's going to be.
That's part of what
I made this book for.
And I'm smart enough to know.
Cool.
Awesome.
Then let's do that.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Jeremy
and I worked together
for a long time, and we play
off each other very well.
And so it's always
a challenge to see
how it's going to be when a
third party gets introduced.
But Claudia just hit
the ground running
and was just very,
incredibly open to feedback.
I don't think we
ever had any-- fight
would be a very strong word--
disagreement about anything.
She was always-- they
are both of a kind
that they accept
that they have not--
they don't know everything,
that they are still learning.
I think they're both kindred
spirits in that, as artists,
they are continually growing and
evolving and listening to what
other people have to say.
And to have them both being
able to have that dialogue
was something really
cool to experience.
JEREMY SALIBA: She was amazing.
She was so generous
with everything.
Is it good?
Do you guys like it?
Is this cool?
And it was always--
more than anything,
it was us saying, oh
yeah, this is awesome.
What do you mean is it cool?
Look at it.
It's great.
You did a great job.
So then anytime where
we would be like,
maybe a little bit-- she'd
be like, oh, I'm sorry.
I did it wrong.
No.
Not at all.
But we're thinking maybe
trying something different
on this page.
And she would immediately
dive in and do it.
And she was amazing.
In terms of collaborating and
everything and communication--
because she was all the
way in Europe-- tremendous.
Email becomes this insane
thing at that point
where you have to really be on
that same page, pun intended,
with everything.
And she was awesome.
Anytime anything
was going on, she
would send us a quick email.
Oh, I'm going to-- this day
I have to do this thing,
so I'll get the
pages to you later.
At one point, she
got really sick.
I'm not going to be
going as fast right now.
We understand.
You're sick.
Then we'd get a ton
of pages anyways.
Oh, I had to work.
I had to get it done.
So there was no egos in
that side of things, which
is probably, I guess,
the biggest concern
in a situation like that.
Well, I think it
should be this way.
And we were all trying
to impress each other.
So I think that made it nice.
AUDIENCE: So speaking
of feedback, what kind
of fan engagement
have you gotten,
feedback from your fans?
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Social media
has been very kind to us.
Twitter was a big one.
Tumblr is a big one.
To a degree, you can actually
measure such things these days
with when the book
gets announced
and you start to get a
little press out there,
people will start
following you on Twitter
or they'll start
following you on Tumblr.
And then some of
the biggest kicks
have been since the book-- so
the book came out in December.
It was only four issues long,
so we were done by March.
And then the first show that
I did, a comic convention,
was Wunderkind down in LA.
And I had my first
Image Comics panel.
And then just having
people come up to us,
doing signings--
I honestly got--
I was on the floor
with our other editor,
and talking to some friends.
And these two women came up
and tapped me on the shoulder
and said, oh hey, I
saw you at the thing,
and I really like
what you had to say,
and I really enjoy your
book, and yada yada.
That guy just took things
to another level there
of fan engagement, if you will.
And I think having our first
signing at the Image Comics
booth at a convention, and then
showing up there and actually
having a few people in line
was really special, too.
JEREMY SALIBA: It freaks me
out when someone recognizes me
at conventions.
Can I get your
autograph, and sign this?
And you check for
the person behind you
and all that kind of stuff.
There's no way.
Are you sure you want me
to ruin what you have here
with my marker and
pen all over it?
But it's been really exciting.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And I
hate to harp back on this,
but it's a significant
element of making comics
these days, which is,
it is social media.
And having people contact me
on Twitter and say, oh, hey,
I read this, and
I really liked it.
Or oh hey, my
great-great-uncle was also
related in such and such way.
And I work at my
local comic shop,
and I'm going to push the book.
And that's just surreal.
AUDIENCE: So maybe you
answered this already,
because that was
kind of my question.
You talk about all
these activities
other than actually writing
and drawing things that
are part of what you're doing.
It seems like a cross
between starting
a small business and
a lifestyle choice
that you're going to live this
whole life and make this stuff.
What's your favorite
part of all the things
you have to do to
actually get to the point
where you have the finished
product, and it's being sold?
JEREMY SALIBA: Is it
the outline for you?
You like outlining a lot.
BRIAN SCHIRMER:
I like outlining.
JEREMY SALIBA: Is it getting
the artwork back and feasting?
Feasting your eyes?
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Part
of it-- part of it
is still, for me, the writing.
I think I realized a few years
ago that I will always write.
I tried to quit
writing a few years ago
and realized I couldn't do it.
So there will always be
that sense of discovery,
and the whole
notion of characters
taking on a life of their own.
And I'm writing
something, and realize
that, oh, I thought this person
was going to die on this page.
Well, no.
They're going to say this
and do this and this.
And that's still cool.
But definitely
getting the art back
and seeing it and
realizing, huh, that's
not really what I
wanted, but it's
way better than
what I envisioned.
And that happens a lot.
And that's something
where it becomes--
dare I say it becomes
kind of magical.
It's like, OK, I had
an idea for something.
I wrote it down
into Google Docs.
And someone on the
other side of the planet
drew something and
sent it back to me
with their interpretation
of what I wrote.
And it's better than what I
originally had in my head.
That's probably the
most uplifting aspect
of the whole thing,
I would have to say.
JEREMY SALIBA: I would say
that on the art side of it,
you have to enjoy just the
process of drawing and painting
or whatever.
You have to enjoy it,
because it's a lot.
And if you don't enjoy
sitting down at your desk
and doing those things, then
you'll end up being bummed.
Because you do it a lot.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: And what you
said is not entirely untrue.
Especially when
it's creator-owned,
it's not-- even though
we have a publisher,
it's not too different
from self-publishing.
Image is great.
Image gets a lot done for us.
It spreads us around.
It gives us promotion.
It's fantastic.
But we are still
the ones who are
taking the ball from the very
beginning to the very end.
One of the things
we didn't mention
is Image does not have editors.
Image did not weigh in one
iota on content, what the book
looked like, any of that.
All the choices were left up
to us, even down to the paper
stock in the comics.
And on the one hand, that's
unlimited freedom, which again,
compared with making films,
is completely different.
But it's also a bit daunting.
It's a lot of
decisions that need
to be made, sometimes
on a daily basis,
frequently on a daily basis,
and sometimes several in a day.
So it's a level of
commitment that I
think somebody really needs to
have to make something happen.
JEREMY SALIBA: As much
as Image does, they also
have a lot of other books.
And you could just rely on
them solely to promote it.
And hopefully that
works out well.
Or you can dig in and
say, well, let's go ahead
and do some of our own,
too, to really make
the most out of this.
And that ties into, I think, the
belief that you did a good job,
the pride you have in a
product that you made,
and saying, I like this.
This is really good.
I think it's worth
getting in people's faces
about, posting it on
media feeds, and saying,
I think you should buy this
book, because it's really cool.
I'm very modest with
that kind of stuff.
I don't ever say, oh,
look at my artwork.
I have a hard time with that.
But with this book,
I really liked it.
I thought we did a great job.
So that was a fun element.
PRESENTER: All right.
That's our time.
Thank you, Brian and
Jeremy, for coming in today.
And if you're on Livestream,
thanks for tuning in.
BRIAN SCHIRMER: Thanks.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]